hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcasts expanding the molecular tool
box for nanopore sequencing your
moderator for today's event before we
start there's a few instructions we want
to hear from you during this interactive
broadcast so please ask questions or
leave us a comment you can do this by
hitting the green button the
presentation window and typing in your
comments and questions we'll try to get
to as many as we can and we'll follow up
if we don't have time today if you want
to go to fullscreen you can enlarge the
slide window by clicking on the screen
icon in the lower right hand corner of
the slide window if you can't hear or
see this presentation on the top make
sure we thanks for tuning in
so as jackie says I've had the naina
port bug for a number of years now my
focus or the company is mainly on
library preparation so how we turn DNA
and RNA into a form that is compatible
with the Nano for sensing device I'm
assuming that some people watching this
presentation will know a fair amount
about altered nanopores technology and
there's some people won't know a thing
so I'm going to spend the first few
minutes talking about the technology and
how it works this slide illustrates
obviously Deadpool's vision for complete
end-to-end solution for
sample to analyze results the aim isn't
to be just a company who makes a
sequencer but provide the whole
end-to-end process from sample bit
blurred leaves cell culture whatever
through sample extraction library
preparation sequencing to full analysis
of the results so returning the
biological information that the
experiment set out to investigate in
terms of sequencing devices we have our
Promethean which is a scalable
high-throughput standalone device which
will be available very soon in fact you
may have seen that we shipped our first
one a couple of weeks ago but for this
presentation I'll be focusing on the min
iron which is the lower throughput
portable device that uses the same
sensing chemistry's that premier time so
everything I'm going to be talking about
this possible on a min I will also be
possible on the Promethean when you can
get one of those the concept of using
that of course to sequence DNA has been
around for a number of data a few
decades now we can see a sketch here
from the notebook of David Deamer
one of the godfathers of nanopore
sequencing in essence you have a nano
pour a small hole sitting in a membrane
of some sort you have an ionic buffer on
either side when an electrical potential
is applied the current of ions flow from
one side to the other through the pore
and an intact in it has an intact DNA
molecule passes through the Nana for the
current changes the current signal being
indicative of the sequence of the DNA
molecules and this is more or less how
we do it today as they'll explain it
looks simple but the challenges in
making it robust and scalable in
high-throughput so another force
consents and any number of molecules it
doesn't have to be DNA or RNA can be
protein and small molecules but for this
presentation I will be focusing on use
of nano force to sequence DNA ok so how
does it work you may have come across
the use of solid-state nano port in
various contexts and we have strong
interests it there but the minnow and
device currently uses protein nanopores
and these have some distinct advantages
for is right now namely that a batch of
protein anaphors will all all more or
less be identical to one another and so
behave in the same reproducible way also
we can modify them using conventional
molecular biology techniques data
and precision to enable us to tune the
properties of banana port okay so the
Nana policy in a membrane not to lift it
in our case because this isn't robust
enough but it's a synthetic polymer
which has high electrical resistance we
add a salty buffer solution to both
sides of the membrane and apply an
electrical current potential sorry
the current given by the ions only flows
through the pores not across the
membrane and we measure the changes in
the current as an analyte passes through
as an analyte passes through the current
is perturb somewhat and the current
reading gives some information about the
type of molecule that's passed through
and different molecules give different
current deflections so when you when
this comes to being a molecule of DNA
the DNA molecule passes through intact
and the number of bases sit within the
pore at any one time so rather than
sequencing a single base you're actually
looking in a small word and so if say
five bases fit into the pore we're
reading those five bases and there are
four to the power five different
combinations possible because there are
four different types of base
so that's 1,024 different possible
currents that a now you might see for
any given word and this sounds like a
lot but when you move the DNA through
the pore one base at a time so as a new
word comes in to the poor it's the same
as the previous we're differing by just
warm bases there are only four different
possible transitions that you might have
and the current transition that you see
will be dependent on the base that's
just entered the pore so GT a or C so
over the course of entire strand we see
a series of current levels each of which
is related to the previous one by four
of the five bases and we can use various
types of our signal processing analyses
to convert this signal into base calls
so you see here the sort of yellow
squiggle of different current levels as
the Strand passes through so there are
three essential components in that at
four so you can see I've talked about
the pawl itself in the membrane in which
then under four sets but I want to talk
a bit about the motor protein which is
the third important part
for sequencing so I talked to the
pre-decided about the need for the DNA
to move one base at time through the
Nano pool so that we can work out what
sequences if you just let the DNA go
through the port unhindered it moves
through far too fast about a million
bases a second which is a beyond us
sequencing freak sampling frequency so
we just don't we just didn't have enough
time to see each base so we slow down
and control the rate of translocation of
the DNA through the pore using a
biological motor protein and this
controls and slows down the DNA and also
acts the ratchet meaning that you see
one base at a time allowing us to
measure the current levels this motor
protein is not attached to the poor if
it were attached to the poor then if
something happened to the motor protein
such as that denaturing then you'd lose
that poor for the rest of the sequencing
run so the motor is actually attached to
the template strands via at DNA adapter
which is ligated on during the library
preparation as the Strand is captured by
the poor the motor starts to move along
the strand of DNA feeling it through the
poor one base at a time the speed at
which the cheating occurs is dependent
on the rate at which the motor processes
the motor protein processes the DNA the
motors we use a tunable with the process
will be controlled by the concentration
certain cofactors adjusting the cofactor
concentration allows us to adjust the
speed of will depending on the
application as well as ligating on a
motor protein adapter we can also we
also ligate on hairpin adapter to the
DNA this covalently linked the two
strands in the duplex together so during
the sequencing because of this hairpin
both strands of the duplex go through so
you get you sequence both strands in at
the locus so as you sequence both
strands we call this a 2d read and
because you're getting to looks at the
same position the accuracy is higher
compared to either strand alone which we
call so either strand alone would be a
1d read once the template it's finished
translocating the motor protein diffuses
away and the ploy is free to capture the
next strand we load templates into the
flow cell at a concentration that
sufficient to minimize open pore time so
one strand is captured almost as soon as
the previous one has finished so the
pores are sequencing pretty much all of
the time so this is a sort of closer
look at the minute as I said it's
handheld portable device and this opens
up the possibility of using it outside
of a laboratory environment the min line
connects to a laptop via USB and the USB
connection provides the power for the
main iron and it's also how the data
gets transferred from the device all the
sequencing reactions take place on the
flow so and that's the consumable part
the main line is you know reusable and
the flow so it's a consumable this
contains the flow so it contains the
pause and the membranes and it's where
the library is loaded underneath the
flow cell we have a custom
application-specific integrated circuit
and as ik which is what controls the
applied potential inks how the
electrical currents are measured the
rest of the device is various bits of
electronics and a fan to help control
the temperature something I'm covered
yet is this or the real-time nature of
the data generation strands pass through
the nanopores intact and the current
levels are measured in as this happens
it's measured in real time as soon as
the strand has thoughts passed through
the pore the data becomes available for
analysis this opens up a lot of
possibilities such as you can stop the
sequencing run as soon as you have
enough data to answer the question that
you set out to or again you can keep
leaving the device running until you see
what you want to see it also means that
you can perform something akin to
sequence capture except that you do it
on device so you sequence the first few
bases of a strand and if it's not from
the region of interest or from the north
and organism of interest you can reject
the strand empty the pool and and search
for a new one this is called read until
and it's easy being pioneered by dr.
Matt Lewis at the University of
Nottingham and he's already published
some pretty neat stuff on this so far so
at any given time 512 nanopores or
capable of sequencing each nanopore acts
independently and is individually
electrically addressable
so all the signal
obtained from single molecules and the
single molecule nature of the sequencing
means that we don't have any phasing
issues which can limit read length of
some sequencing by synthesis platforms
also the electrical measurements use do
not result in Nanna poor or motor
damaged so that the quality of the DNA
signal does not deteriorate over time
therefore there really are no
limitations to the read length of the
technology and indeed it's been proven
capable of producing very very long
reads and as far as we can tell the only
thing which limits the read length is
the quality of the input DNA itself so
if you're interested in having a go with
the mid line it is available and we
would encourage you to go to our website
wwlp.com for more information about how
to get hold of one it you can also
purchase consumable from our online shop
there's a strong and supportive online
community where you're able to discuss
ideas get tips and find collaborators
the participants with min iron pilot the
technology they develop applications and
tools and publish on these also we're
rapidly developing products and upgrades
and updates being released at regular
interval intervals in the communities
the best place to keep up to date with
the state of the art so there have been
plenty of publications over 50 and they
you know keep increasing in number so
publications and tools are being
released from the nanopore community of
a range of applications pathogen
analysis surveillance meta-genome
metagenomics and tools and methods
including de novo sequencing and
assembly so all available through the
community okay so after the introduction
I'd like to move on to discuss what my
work focuses on which is library
preparation so library prep is the
process of converting extracted DNA or
RNA or amplicons into a format that is
compatible with the sequencing system
shown here for genomic DNA I so ultra
nanopore standard G DNA library prep is
reasonable is relatively quick and
straightforward to perform and it's
capable of generating very long
fragments of DNA which will give you
long reads
let's start with the user can share
their DNA if they like but it's not a
prerequisite obviously if you want very
long reads then you know you wouldn't
want to share your DNA but it does make
sense for some applications and I'll
come back to that I'll come back to that
in more detail in a minute
so after sharing or not the fragments
are then and repaired and a single
Addison Dennison base is added to the
three prime end then DT tailed adapters
are located on one of the adapters is
the hairpin as we've discussed
previously which connects the two
strands in the duplex and allows for a
strand to be sequence followed by for
this complement all part to sit all part
of the same sequencing read at the
opposite ends the hairpin we have a
fault shaped adapter and this other
adapter contains various features it has
a single stranded section meaning that
the strands are he more easily captured
and threaded through the port has the
motor protein preloaded which means that
as the strands pass through they go at
the right speed and it also has a region
where we hybridize tethering
oligonucleotide this tether has a
hydrophobic group which helps drag all
of the molecules in the library down
onto the membrane bringing a much lotion
context the Nano pores and this
increases our sensitivity several
thousand fold
after you've ligated on your adapters we
perform an enrichment step where we
select four hairpin containing molecules
this allows us to maximize the yield of
2d reads so all the reads so these are
the retirees the reads where you observe
both the templates Rhenish reverse
complement so the way you do this is
after the ligation you add an oligo
which Emile's to the hairpin and this
all ago also has a hook to facilitate
subsequent binding to streptavidin
coated beads so you add your tethered
molecules to beads anything with a
hairpin binds everything without a
hairpin is washed away
and so when you aleut the DNA from the
beads you are left with every molecule
having a hairpin so every weed should be
a 2d read
now we do we observe improved raw / read
accuracy with the 2d prep compared to a
1d equivalent as I say because you get
two looks at each strand it's it's two
slightly better but improvement recent
improvements in our chemistry have led
to improved accuracy with 1d reads so
now it's worthwhile as offering a 1d
library prep protocol and it works in a
very similar manner to the 2d protocol
the main difference being that during
the ligation you omit the hairpin
adapter and you don't perform a hairpin
selection step but no additional
reagents are required in order to
perform the 1d or the 2d library
preparation the key is the same so I
mentioned briefly about users being able
to share or not share their DNA so just
return to that unless you need very long
reads in other words if you need reads
that are greater than 20 KB in length
then we would normally recommend
shearing the reason for this is that it
means that you're able to bring all of
the fragments into a uniform range which
is below the sort of size where you may
get unwanted shearing during the prep so
if you have fragments that say 50 KB in
length this is the sort of size range
we're preparing up and down could
possibly share them so if you get
shearing during the library prep then it
means that you won't have adapters on
both ends of your DNA which will means
that you'll get reduced 2d yields so if
you don't need anything so if you're
happy with under 10 KB reads then we'd
recommend sharing so you know the
library prep is quite is similar to
other library prep protocols out there
for other sequencing technologies but
two things that to point out is that it
is PCR free and you don't need to PC all
your samples which you know is a
laborious process and it introduces bias
and you lose the epigenetic tags also
you don't need to do its source
selection isn't a prerequisite because
there's no read there's no read length
required you don't need to to do a size
selection to remove anything too big or
anything too small you know you can just
throw the lot at it at the nana point it
will sequence what you give it so you
know it does have advantages over over
other library prep protocols so when we
launched the minion in May 2014 we
released a sample prep kit to go with it
and it was by far from perfect so in
those days we did not perform a hairpin
selection after the ligation so there's
no enrichment for 2d molecules - got a
lot of 1d data which you know you may
not have wanted as well as having a
motor on the fourth y-shaped adapter
there's an additional hairpin motor to
assist in the sequencing of complement
molecules this had to be loaded onto the
hairpin at the very end of the prep and
early on we made regular iterative
improvement in upgrades to the protocol
to generate improved yields improve data
quality improve the customer experience
and we sort of made these regular
improvements and in August 2015 we
released kit 6 which included an
upgraded motor protein which allowed us
to get rid of the troublesome hairpin
motor we upgraded the hairpin selection
technique which improved our yield we
increase the sequencing speed which
doubled the throughput and represented a
significant improvement in performance
and this protocol was and is performing
you know very robustly in the field
we're now in the process of releasing
our latest chemistry kit 7 and once
again this represents significant
upgrade and both sequencing chemistry to
improve rule read accuracy and
sequencing speed we haven't just made
improvements to our standard kit we've
released other kits during this time to
expand the toolbox and empower customers
to broaden their horizons in September
2014 we released a CD and a kit allowing
customers to get students engaged from
their RNA samples in June of 2015 we
released our first iteration of a bar
coding kit allowing customers to run
multiple sound causing multiplex on a
single flow cell and in November 2015 we
released
it's facilitating seating of low input
samples without the need for PCR and in
February 2016
we released a piece your free bar coding
kit so as I say we're about to move on
to release of kit 7 and this is
accompanied by change in flow cell
chemistry namely an upgrading pour from
our 7r9 and we also changed the base
calling algorithm from hmm RR n n
recurring neural networks and these
changes mean that all 2d accuracy will
read accuracy goes up to 95% and r1d
rule read accuracy goes up to 90% this
90% for 1d reads is higher than when we
started for 2d reads back in May 2014
so as such library preps that now offer
1d reads rather than 2d reads actually
starts become useful 1d libraries give
you improved throughput over a 2d
library as more time spent looking at
different fragments of DNA in a 2d prep
it takes twice as long to sequence a
piece of DNA as you have to look at both
strands so I'd like to spend a bit of
time just looking at some of the new
kits that that we've released and that
we've been working on so the standard
kit requires an input of about half a
microgram to one microgram of starting
material and this provides sufficient
DNA to reload a flow cell four times or
you could load for separate flow cells
if a customer had less than five hundred
nano grams of starting material it was
normally recommended the template on the
word underwent PCR amplification to
boost that level up to one microgram
well for certain applications and
previously mentioned perform PCR is not
necessarily appropriate if you're
consumed with bias for example if you're
trying to assemble a genome which
contains repetitive regions that may not
amplify so well then you might get
reduced coverage in certain areas of the
genome which will hamper the assembly or
if you're trying to identify different
populations from a meta genomic soup
then you may not want to risk losing
certain hot or amplified genomes that
you know for example they may be GC rich
not amplify so well it means that you
wouldn't get a perfect as good a
representation in your subsequent
sequencing of your starting population
alternatively maybe interesting-looking
epigenetic tags in your template which
you'll and you'll lose that information
in the PCR and you know performing PCR
of long molecules can be a lengthy
process
adding several hours to to prep time if
you're concerned over sample prep time
delaying your time to result and having
to perform a lengthy PCR is far from
ideal so having access to a PCR free low
input prep would be attractive from them
several angles and in order to fulfill
this demand we developed a precede PCR
free method of preparing a library in
situations where you have a low input
and in fact if you so if you use this
PCR free low input expansion kit you can
from as little as 20 nanograms of
purified G DNA you can obtain almost the
same throughput as if you were doing
preparing from one microgram of G DNA
using the standard kit and it's a very
similar workflow to the to the ordinary
care however there is warm subtle and
significant difference is that rather
than eluting hairpin selected DNA from
the strep beads you leave the DNA on the
bead and add the bead bound sample
directly to the flow cell the beads are
heavy and fall towards the the membrane
in the pore by gravity and this helps
increase the potency of the library in
the in the plot lower right you can see
the difference between eluting DNA and
leaving it on bead so here we've prepped
14 anagrams of lambda DNA and we diluted
the sample following following the
standard protocol so off off beat all we
followed the low input protocol and left
the DNA on bead and you can see that the
Ombuds method generates about three
times the throughput when you're talking
about starting with low amount but i
would like to mention that it's not to
be a replacement for the standard
library prep because we have observed in
an on as yet uncharacterized bias away
from very long fragments when the
library is left on the bead an
experiment shown we prepped at 20 kb
amplicon and the library was either left
on bead
blew or removed from the bead shown in
pink and the the upper plot shows that
to the read length distribution observed
the two different methods and you can
see that when the libraries are looted
from the strip bead you get a large
proportion of your basis from the four
next molecules which is nice however
when the sample is left on the bead you
observe an increase in shorter fragments
and it's the same PCR product and it's
the same beads but there appears to be
some uncharacterized phenomenon that
results in but they're in a slight bias
away from the very longest fragments
when the DNA when DNA loaded beads are
added to the flow cell in the instant in
the example where the sample is g-tube
fragmented there's no significant
difference in in the read length you can
see from the from the green and the
yellow plots that if you're talking
about gee two fragments centered around
sort of sixth AKB then there's there's
notice bias isn't seen furthermore the
technique hasn't been validated fuse
with our wash kit yet so we haven't
tested the efficacy of the wash kit to
remove beans from the flow cell it may
work we just haven't tested it yet so if
I haven't done so already I'd like to
say that we haven't observed an upper
limit to the read length of the mid iron
the read length that you observe is is
directly dependent on the fragment
length of the input material so if you
put short stuff in you'll get shorts to
foul if you have long fragments in your
sample then you should observe them so
here we show the image of complete 2d
read that measured 255 KB in length so
this translates to 510 KB of the at DNA
pardon me
255 KB of the first strand and then you
get to the hairpin which connects it to
its complement and then you see 255 KB
of its complement strand the hairpin
contains a seamless motif that is easily
identifiable by be the base calling
software and it indicates that the read
is a bonafide a 2d read the sample in
particular was from an e coli prep where
the DNA was extracted using a kaijin 500
tip the read was the read was aligned
using blast and it had a mean Q score of
10.1 as far as I'm aware this is the
longest complete 2d read that we have
achieved to date we may have achieved
and sequencing longer 1d molecules I'm
not sure about that we are working on
getting longer but this will take
improvement in our sample extraction and
library prep technique which is what is
limiting our relinked at the moment so
as I've said that the real ink that you
get out of the mid line is approach to
the fragments that you put in
currently we haven't found an extraction
technique that does not produce some
short fragments and if you have any
short fragments in your prayer even if
they don't appear significant on a gel
or a bio analyzer then you're likely to
see them on the minion even if the short
rags don't contribute much in mass to
the final sample they will have a high
molarity compared with the long stuff so
you know if you've got 25 10 kV
molecules that will have the same mass
as 1 250 KB molecule but you know
there's 25 more of your 10 KB molecules
to you know a large excess in terms of
molarity and if anyone knows of any
extraction method that isolates or
produces exclusively long fragments and
I'd be very interested in hearing about
it but in the meantime until we've
improved our technical method we we've
been working with the blue Pippen from
Sage to enrich for long fragment present
in the sample and we developed a large
but protocol to enrich for molecules
that are over 40 KB in length and the
graphs displayed on the right hand side
we take a sample of extracted G DNA
e.coli in this case and we prep two
different libraries neither a fragmented
but one is not so selected that's the
upper graph and one is so isolating
that's the lower graph and you can see
the striking enrichment for long
fragments in the lower plot it's not say
that you don't get the long fragment
without the site selection but they are
accompanied by an excess of shorter
molecules the protocol which should be
released soon if it hasn't already
allows the user to achieve almost
exclusively long fragments the size
selection is done is virtually the last
step it's done after the ligation of the
actors we do it this way so as to
minimize manipulation of the sample
after the size selection we've compared
the size selection of input material so
you size selects before your library
prep with size selection of the ligated
library and observe that you get better
enrichment when the size selection is
done at the end we assume that during
the library prep you are you know you're
getting some fragmentation during the
manipulation the petting and the beard
steps and this is causing shearing of
the DNA so you're getting you're
generating some small fragments during
the prep so if you do the size selection
right at the very end you minimize the
manipulation required before running it
so even though as I said on our standard
library prep protocol is relatively
simple it takes about 70 minutes it
doesn't require the laborious process of
site selection or amplification but it
still takes over an hour even for a
skilled user and for certain
applications we envisage the need for a
more rapid and a more simple library
prep for using in the clinic when the
field where time to answer is critical
or access to lab equipment is limiting
so fulfill this need we've been working
on a rapid sample prep and are in the
process of releasing this kit in
protocol and it facilitates the
generation of 1d molecules from
extracted DNA in around 10 minutes the
kit is transpose days based relies on
the fragmentation of template G DNA
Moloch G DNA molecules and the
simultaneous tagging of the fragmented
template with adapter sequences using a
transpose age molecular protein post
transposition as this the process of
fragmentation takes about two minutes
and after the transposition a sequencing
adapter is ligated onto the adapted
tagged ends and to facilitate an anaphor
so you can see here we compare here we
compare the the output the expected
output of a rapid 1d kick with a with a
standard 2d library so a 70 minute
sample prep time in this case where the
DNA again was using e.coli so you can
see that
from the throughput graph on the right
in kilobytes per channel per hour the
standard log prep does offer an improved
throughput but it does take an hour
longer and you also observe from the
read length plots on the left-hand side
of the graphs that you get a narrow
range for the GT fragmented stuff and
the rapid prep offers are much longer
much longer reads or although the median
fragment length does tend to be a bit
shorter so you know it does offer some
opportunities for time to answers it
only takes ten minutes so I've called
this this slide decisions decisions as
you can tell we have various different
library prep protocols and workflows and
kits that on the face of things all seem
to do similar things you know they
facilitate the generation of sequencing
data from extracted G DNA but each
protocol does have its own sort of
advantages and limitations so here I
compare our various G DNA sample prep
workflows and show the input
requirements the prep time and the
output that you might expect hoping this
sort of comparison could act as a guide
to help customers decide which workflow
is for them depending on what their
signaling priorities are such as you
know time to resolve throughput or read
length the highest throughput is
achieved using the standard prep method
so g2 fragmentation followed by adapter
ligation so if getting the most
sequencing Gator your end and that's the
post bore you should use the other
methods gives different throughput so
important down to the nature of the
different prep so the rapid 1d care
states transpose a is based and when we
run a transpose A's fragmented library
versus a GG fragmented library we
observe a type of block not observed in
a GT fragmented library and we currently
attribute this block to the transpose
itself and although it's rare it does
limit the throughput the throughput of
the unfragmented samples is reduced for
a different reason in this case the
molecules are much longer as they're not
been fragmented and therefore they're
fewer in number so the molar
concentration is reduced it takes a bit
longer for the poor to find a molecule
to sequence so the poor isn't sending
all the time and your throughput is
reduced
this reason some very long weeds also
talked about a real egg now if some very
long reads are achieved with with both
the rapid Kip and and a fragmentation
free ligation method but the majority of
the basis sequence are from fragments
under 10 KB so if you look at the the
graphs on the right the sort of blue and
the yellow plot so there you've got
rapid versus a non size selected
unfragmented you can see that you've got
some long fragments but a lot of short
stuff in there as well if you want
exclusively long fragments then we
recommend the size selection protocol
which is shown in the bottom right
because that gives you almost
exclusively the long fragments well
alternatively you know maximizing your
throughput or ultra long reads might not
be what you need you might need to time
to the result satisfied very quickly so
but maybe the rapid 1d prep would be for
you so I want to talk now a little bit
about bar coding or bar coding kit
allows users to pool and sequence
multiple amplicons or small genomes in a
single sequencing run and this makes
more efficient use of the sequencing
power of the flow so in the first
version of the kit barcodes are
introduced into libraries by PCR so you
attach generic adapters on to your
template by ligation these adapters
contain primer binding sites to
facilitate downstream PCR so the PCR to
perform with a primer pair that
recognizes the generic adapters but also
contain a unique bar code sequence as
well so the amplified products contain
the unique sequence in a bar coded so
the different samples after they've been
amplified with different bar codes
so so then you've taken other samples
and you can modify them with the same
adapter but amplify them with different
primer pairs and they'll have different
barcodes on so after amplification and
cleanup samples can be pooled and then
sequencing adapters so the sequencing
adapters are the the y-shaped and the
hairpin shaped adapters there can be
ligated onto the pooled sample all the
samples are sequenced together and the
data can be separated out on the basis
of bark
it used to be that we just used to add a
barcode on to one end of the of the
other molecules but we we found that we
get an improved champa and pre
percentage of identifying barcodes when
you introduce pockets at both ends we
now Institute barcodes at both ends
which offers as a substantial
improvement and we've recently expanded
the set available from 12 barcodes to 96
barcodes so to demonstrate the efficacy
of this largest set of baggage we
designed pre PCR primers to 96 different
regions of e.coli and we attached a
different bar codes each amplicon so
following barcode devilish following
barcode deconvolution each set of reads
was aligned to the reference genome and
the coordinates coordinates of hits were
plotted in Spotfire for each barcode the
size of the plot circle represents the
percentage of reads at each position and
the 96 bar code segregated cleanly with
90% of the reads having a barcode
identified and not about nine ninety
eight point eight percent of the reads
had the correct barcode so we also offer
a PC or three we as of February 2016 we
now offer a method of bar coding without
the need for PCR so PCR free as I've
said PCR is not always appropriate you
know you may not amplify your sequences
efficiently and evenly getting a getting
bias piece your struggles with long
fragments you might there be a limit to
the read length that you could that you
could do as well so a PCR free method
will be attractive and we currently
offer 12 unique pcre barcodes so in this
case the sample is da tailed separately
using standard techniques and unique DT
tailed barcode adapter is ligated on
access the barcode is removed by be
clean up and the bar coded barcode
modified samples got them cooled again
generic sequencing adapters why in
hairpin shaped adapt so ligated on to
the paul makes before sequencing it's
normal
and the graph just shows a mix of the 12
barcodes all being identified and
separated so from the timeline that I
showed earlier you can be sure that
we're not resting
you know we're endeavoring to broaden
the scope of what is possible in library
prep this is just what we've done so far
but we're hoping to expand our rapid
toolkit and all of our tool kits and
you'll be able to hear more about the
latest developments at our upcoming
conference London Calling some of you
changing tack slightly from from the
type of prep done by users I want to
talk now about our volt rack product
some of you may have seen this it's in
development now and hopefully will be
available to customers soon for those of
you who aren't familiar with the device
essentially it's a minion sized sample
and library preparation device it's
fully automated with all the larger
preparation steps occurring on the
device it's entirely powered by USB it
makes the whole process truly portable
and easy and reproducible as well we
envisage this you know removing the need
for complex sample prep procedures and
expensive lab equipment and removing
user variation has been very attractive
at first we offer we hope to offer a
standard ligation based 1d and 2d sample
prep and a bar coding workflow to allow
the processing of multiple samples we've
run some preliminary experiments and the
results promising at this stage
eventually the device will be compatible
with all of all IV preps that we have
including cDNA and PCR based preps in
the first instance customers will be
adding extracted DNA to the device but
ultimately we'll be tuning the device
that it's capable of extracting the DNA
or RNA from from your sample as well as
performing the library preparation so
the user will just have to add a bit of
their sample to the device again you'll
be hearing more about this
this product at London Calling so I'd
like to finish now and the time I got
left with a few applications of the
technology firstly I'd like to talk
about the novo assembly of microbial
genomes so using short read sequences to
try and assemble a genome is
it's like taking a jigsaw or rather
because you want 30 30 X 30 copies of
the same jigsaw only with each one cut
slightly differently and then all the
pieces mixed together the short reads
you know the equivalent of having very
small jigsaw pieces and to find where
the two pieces fit together requires a
lot of searching it makes for a
substantial computational challenge and
the results tend to be imperfect pearl
it is particularly difficult to assemble
genomes that contain repetitive regions
for example the bigger your pieces get
say 5 KB instead of a hundred bases then
the task becomes a lot easier and you
can start to resolve repeats that are a
few KB in length as the read length goes
up the job gets even easier so 50 KB it
gets much easier we are at the point yet
we can routinely generate reads of 500
KB but as I say we have seen you know
we've seen we've seen over hundreds of
KB long it's just really a question of
getting integrity of DNA so you know if
you imagine e coli which is you know
four and a half mega bases if you've got
500,000 bases then it's only nine pieces
of the genome so the challenge becomes
not a lesser computational challenge and
more trying to make sure you can extract
him manipulate DNA strap in such a way
that they don't break so we wanted to
test our ability to assemble a genome
using only nan at full reads we started
off with something small and the DNA we
used the DNA only donated by Chantel
Abigail from Marseille and the DNA comes
from quite an interesting source they
discovered a virus in Siberian
permafrost that had been there for more
than 30,000 years the virus particle is
enormous by viral standards it's 1.5
microns long and they were able to
resurrect this viral particle in the lab
as they point out in their paper as the
permafrost permafrost is thawing out the
abilities of viruses to come back to
life after tens of thousands of years
could have some quite worrying
ramifications
anyway we weren't interested too much in
the biology with more interested in
assembly Magina
and as it turned out was fairly rich a
tea rich so unfortunately had to PCR the
library which was unfortunate but we
didn't have much much DNA so we had to
PCI and with a lot of help from the
moment as well to be honest he did the
whole thing actually we were able to
assemble the whole genome in twists in a
single contech so that's one fragment
covering the whole genome and as you can
see in the normal plot of the assembly
against the published reference things
match up well so then the next slide is
an improvement on this sometime last
year a landmark paper came out in Nature
Methods by Nick loam and Josh quick and
Jared Simpson and they demonstrated
that's possible
using only manifold reads to assemble a
bacterial genome into us into a single
Contech with with very high percent
identity at 99.9 percent identity
eventually so we wanted to see that all
sounded great but we wanted to see if we
could do it ourselves so we we took some
ecoli DNA that that we had that we have
to have in our -80 freezer and we made a
couple of libraries one of the libraries
were standard library they made by
fragmenting the G DNA as described and
the fragment friendly distributions
around six KB the other library was
prepared in a similar way but submitting
the fragmentation step and it contained
some very long fragment CT from the pin
plot we got reads over 100 KB and we
wanted to see what the effect of having
these long reads would have on the
assembly so we took 40 X coverage of the
6 KB data we put it through PB CR and
dis merit correction and fed the reads
into the salera assembler and we've got
assembled into several in this assembled
into several contexts when we repeated
the assembly with a mixture of 6 kb
fragments in some ultra long reads so
this time instead of using 40 x
coverage we took 10 x
6 6 kb and 10x of manga fragments and
did the same thing
put it through PBR and slur assembler in
this case we've got to assemble into one
Contech which is not so not all that
surprising but it is nice to see so the
bottom line is that you know long weeds
make de novo assembly assembly easy just
hammer the point home I do have one more
slide on it so for another project we
had running we isolated a flavor
bacterium from river water which as it
turned out is not in the refseq database
we assumed it proved to be a difficulty
no to assemble it's found to be over 8
sorry over 60% 80 rich so after a number
of different sequencing runs where some
of the libraries have been selected and
some of the libraries hadn't been
selected we had a large repository of
sequencing data covering a wide range of
readings and we wanted to see what
effect different read Lane libraries
would have on either 70 so the most to
assemble it into three context one
chromosome of about 5 mega bases in a
couple of plasmids when we took 200 mega
mega bases so about 40 X coverage of 5
KB reads and above that generated 15
context so many more than would possible
but when we took two hundred Meg's of 10
KB reads in above that gave three
context so the same amount of data just
where the reads were twice as long
vastly improved the assembly and the
trend continues and as you get longer
reads less data is required to achieve
complete assembly so if you take over 15
KB reads that required 25 X coverage
over 20 KB KB read required 20 X
coverage and over 30 KB reads required
only 15 X coverage to assemble into
three contexts so if you've got long
reads you require less coverage to
assemble so even though the size
selection might seem like a costly route
it can make the final computational
analysis easier and cheaper and
ultimately better I talk quickly about
sequence capture I'm running out of time
so I won't going to in too much detail
safe to say that
large genomes from alien GM's and plant
genomes currently not not currently
possible on single flow cell for the
minion the output of the flow cell isn't
sort of in the gigabase range it's well
within the range of it promethium which
is 300 times more powerful but for a
million not not yet but to bring the
biology of large genomes into reach you
can use secret capture where you enrich
for the regions of interest using
pulldown probes which can then anything
the reasons of interest binds to the
probes which are specific for those
regions of interest and you can pull
these probes out using beads wash away
anything that you don't want and then
loop off the beads the region of
interest so you've enriched for it and
we tried this using so what we did is we
took the item short select small cancer
pro so panel and which about 150 genes
and we got some sample DNA from Coryell
which contained snip in the bracket one
region
we ran the standard protocol as
recommended by the supply and we were
able to detect the the known snips in
the target regions by doing sequence
capture we are planning to offer tools
for detecting snips and other sequin to
capture workflows using our real time
data analysis software and hopefully a
protocol will be available there are
tools for doing this out you know
elsewhere so you know you don't have to
wait for for that next and finally I
guess I'd like to talk about a real-time
application for species identification
that we call what's in my plot will win
for sure as I mentioned earlier as soon
as a strand of DNA has passed through
the ploy can be base called and then
analyzed in the WIMP workflow species
are identified and classified in real
time the classification relies in this
classification sorry the output that you
get is the taxon ID which for which a
classification score is computed the
higher the score the more confident that
we can be that the classification
classification was correct in the output
you see here blue is very confident and
yellow is is less confident
and the user can set thresholds set
confidence thresholds depending on
whether the aim is to achieve maximum
specificity or maximum sensitivity and
this application is available through
octave nanopore so the database was
recently expanded to include viruses as
well at bacteria we wanted to test how
well it works
they bought range of viral RNAs from a
commercial supplier we prepared the
libraries and sequence them and put them
through the workflow so when we ran
through so when we ran through the WIMP
workflow we obtained that the taxonomic
tree on the left as I say the blue was
with high confidence and yellow was with
low confidence so you can see from the
color codes that we were able to there
viruses were all were identified by
women with high confidence as well as
running the libraries through through
the WIMP workflow we also barcode at
each library so that we could look at
how well the WIMP read counts correspond
it to the actual reads we got in wanted
to know if the WIMP workflow would
introduce any bias or if it was
quantitative so the bar chart on the
right shows the two sets of reads to
agree closely so the dark bar is for the
WIMP reads and you can see they match
well with the number of reads obtained
number of barcode reads so we were
pleased that this was quantitative this
slide showed more data on the
quantitative nature of wind but as I'm
running out of time I won't go through
it I'll just proceed directly to a sort
of worked example of of wind so we
thought about looking at cows milk it's
a good sample because drinking
unpasteurized cow's milk is something
you have fun at the moment and although
it currently tastes amazing there is a
downside to it the whole reason that
milks milk gets pasteurized in the first
place is that raw milk is got pathogenic
bacteria in it the table at the top
shows its non common people become ill
from drinking raw cow's milk and it's
not massively surprising the table below
lists some of the pathogens commonly
found in unpasteurized milk some pretty
nasty stuff in this Listeria in e.coli
and so on
so we took some raw raw cow's milk and
we left it on the bench for a few days
at room temperature to let it cook there
to let the stuff grow in it and then
extracted the DNA and to make sure
absolutely sure that we know we would
that we would have something to see
respites in some Listeria DNA into the
cow's milk and then we did this Adelaide
we prepped in the sequencing and put it
through the bacterial wimp workflow and
when we analyzed we see lots of
bacterial species present in the milk
though ones that you looked that you'd
expect to see like lactic Caucus and
Pseudomonas but what-what was quite
interesting is that we saw a good number
of species or identify the ones that are
known to cause mastitis mastitis in
dairy cows is depicted by at least a
necrosis of other tissues shown in the
photo now the milk that we got was
presumed from several cows so we can
trace it back to there's specific
animals but mr. Isis affects up to fifty
percent of dairy cattle so it's you know
pretty certain that this was a real
discovery of the disease a real
detection of the disease and what we
also see is that you can see the spike
in the steering with very high
confidence and the number of recounts
was more or less exactly the same as the
amount that we added as you'd expect
from from a quantitative workflow and
this kind of illustrates the sorts of
things to which you know Minaya and
associated workflows can be put in
highlights than non lab applications in
environments that you can that you can
use that this can be used in I mean you
can see how useful this workflow in
combination with a portable sequence it
would be in monitoring health and
well-being of dairy animals and you know
our ambitions aren't limited to the
confines of this planet that you might
have seen in the press that there are
plans to send a minion up on to the
International Space Station this year
making it the first DNA sequencer in
space initially the idea is to see
whether or not it's possible to sequence
in space samples that have been prepared
on earth but in the longer term plan
would be to use minions monitor
astronaut health you know monitoring
intestinal microbiome and water supplies
for example but who knows detecting it
terrestrial life maybe so I will finish
there I just want to acknowledge all the
stuff automatic for technologies
particularly in the applications
department dan Turner and Dan Fordham in
the engineering department and Jones in
data analysis team fernando amber and
and oh I assume that's referring to how
what's the lowest input that can get
right okay so I showed on a previous
slide that we could achieve pretty
decent throughput with little as 20
nanograms input we have gone down lower
than this and we have seen reads
detected in the sort of tens tens of
picogram range so tends to maybe a
hundred people range you do see weeds
but you know vast you know that
compromises throughput you do see a
reduction in the throughput when you
start with with under 20 nanograms but
for certain applications if if you don't
need to see many reads you know if
you're just doing species or
identification rather than you know
assembly and you just interested in
knowing the presence or absence of
something then you can you could start
with with a lower than 20 nanograms but
just people just that you know
understand that you're not going to see
the source of
high throughput set that you might see
if you started with 20 nanograms well I
mean the advantages of of using
nanopores
none of for sequencing you know it's
it's single molecule is PCR free and
it's long read so you know the
advantages that you'd have over 17 any I
don't know if it's necessarily limited
to bacterial but yeah the assembly is
easier with the longer bleeds because
it's PCR free you can see any epigenetic
tags that you might that you might be
interesting there might be lost in PCR
you know it's and it's within you know
if you wanted to do assembly it's within
range of the minion as well you know you
can get good coverage and you know do
you know genomic assembly I'm not sure
if that necessarily answer your
questions I hope so yeah that's a very
good question you know the advantage of
not having to do PCR and you know the
fact is you know you're not sequencing a
copy of a copy of a copy you're
sequencing you know the real thing so
yes you can you can see epigenetic tags
at the moment we we don't offer at data
analysis software 2d convolute the
epigenetic tags but I believe that this
is something that we you know we're
looking into and in the process of
trying to to offer but yes you can see
them it just I think it takes a little
bit
hacking at the user ends to try and make
use of the data but but it is but it is
in there yeah that's that's a good
question
so if you have Nicks sort of dotted
around your your template then as you
trot as you as you as the most proteins
processing the DNA and feeding it
through the poor if you get to a nick
then the strand will terminate there the
read will terminate there you won't
continue on you won't get to the hairpin
and you won't go around the corner you
won't see the complement so you would
lose the 2d information because of the
Nick you would still get a partial 1d
read you know be a bit shorter than the
fragment length that that you could have
potentially had but the 1d because of
the improvements in incidence in
chemistry that we have you know the 1d
reads now are you know are pretty good
so the data that you that you'd get from
that truncated wandering read would
still be useful but yeah Nick's would
would lead to premature your termination
and loss of data they also lead to or
rather we believe that they lead to
possible blocking of nanopores as well
we're not entirely sure how this how
this works or exactly the mechanism for
this and for and I don't have a slide on
it but if you take genomic DNA and you
treat it with an enzyme which which will
generate one randomly gaps in your DNA
and you run it against a library that
has not been treated in that way you see
a higher degree of block
and that much reduced throughput from
the library that has been treated you
know forgetting about the fact that the
the connecting and gapi sample also has
a much lower percent of 2d reads and you
know short of read length the amount of
data that you get is also vastly reduced
so yeah they are a problem in terms of
the app the the total yield and the
quality and read length of yield as well
as also edges but you can try in in you
can remove nicks and gaps are trying to
minimize their effect by using repair
module from any be called FFP repair
which has enzymes in it which should
help ameliorate that problem remove the
next resolve them and seal any gaps
alternatively if you have a very highly
nicked sample you can PCR it the the
piece of fragments that you that you
generate work shouldn't have mix or gaps
in and should perform better you know
you don't want to pee soil and you don't
have to but in this instance you know
you could this recession so thank you
and